we are taking calls for the first first
time of the year first time of 2018
at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 I can't tell if
this is a caller from country code 44 or
from area code 443 but you're on with me
hello there 3 yeah I think are you still
there caller from for 4-3 or country
code for for any area I know you can
hear well you must be able to hear me
because I hear you
we could just barely hear you let's it
speak up as much as you can make sure
we're not on speakerphone go ahead okay
um I'm calling from Baltimore Maryland
okay um my name is Micah Rogers um yes
my question is like um this sounds kind
of elitist in a way but do you think
that that we should have tests for for
voting no like driving test no we
shouldn't we shouldn't because listen I
get it right if if voter turnout were
higher progressives would do way better
if there was a voting test that sought
to identify some basic set of knowledge
unbalance it would probably be better
for the left although it depends on
exactly you know what the questions were
or whatever the problem with the voting
test aside from the fact that I believe
it would be completely unconstitutional
and that that's a pretty big thing and
big reason that that I'm against it if
those things can be used the same way as
tests for being for being allowed to
have kids the the way in which those
ideas can be perverted to be
discriminatory along all sorts of
horrible lines on all sorts of protected
classes is really really bad so I
understand I sympathize with the reasons
why you might want to think about
something like that but no I would be
against that I think it's a bad idea you
agree Pat oh absolutely and we had those
tests during the Jim Crow era and we all
know how that went
yeah aside from that it would be gone
constitutional which isn't necessarily
an argument against
in principle I mean he can always amend
the Constitution sure but I think it's a
bad idea
yeah and Mark I think that there are
other ways to at least try to solve the
problem of an uninformed electorate
although right now there's a lot of
factors making making it worse so I
understand why you're asking that but no
I would be against that all right mmm
all right thanks very much appreciate it